over the weekend there was a horrible
incident involving a fire at Trump Tower
in New York City that led to a death and
the story has lessons not only about
sort of the moral depravity of the guy
in the Oval Office which isn't news at
this point but also about cronyism and
regulation and a lot of other important
areas and as the story goes a fire broke
out at Trump Tower Saturday it killed an
art dealer named Todd brass nur in his
50th floor condo the condo did not have
sprinklers this is the second fire at
Trump Tower this year there was a small
one on the roof of the building in
January and it turns out that Donald
Trump actually fought sprinkler
legislation in New York City which would
have required that this building be
fully sprinklered because new buildings
already have that requirement in New
York City same thing here in Boston and
that arguably would have prevented this
death and in 1998 after a couple of
fatal fires in New York City then Mayor
Rudy Giuliani was pushing for mandating
landlords landlords to retrofit
sprinklers into their buildings and
Trump and lots of other big real estate
developers it wasn't just Trump doing
this they all didn't want to spend the
money that it would cost to retrofit
their buildings with sprinklers they
were grandfathered in in the law that
was eventually signed and didn't have to
do it and the law said ok old buildings
are grandfathered in new buildings have
to have sprinklers and of course
Republicans are saying listen Trump was
a Democrat back then you can't really
blame him for doing that or this isn't
unique to Trump I agree that this wasn't
at all unique to Trump but I think the
more interesting story here is the
regulation piece right there's this idea
from some on the right that you don't
actually need to pass legal regulation
because businesses in the free market
have an incentive to just regulate
themselves
blah blah blah insert free-market sort
of dogma here we know that that doesn't
happen
right we know that that doesn't happen
because we saw the sugar plant where
someone died in a mountain of sugar
after there was not a safety device put
in that regulations were pushed for and
we have endless examples of this and I
feel like if there's any lesson here
it's not Trump is a bad guy we learned
that a long time ago it's not business
people like to save money
it's that the idea that there's this
sort of self-regulating method in the
free market of business where no one
would ever do anything bad because then
it would be bad for their business it
just doesn't happen
it doesn't happen and we need regulation
and it's abundantly clear well in this
example how many Trump towers are there
like if you want addresses that were met
on the 50th story how many options do
you have
New York City I guess dozens I don't
know I guess and this particular example
makes me so angry because I just watched
there's a new documentary on Netflix
about Donald Trump it's a four part I
can't remember the name it something
Trump yeah but in it they talked about
when he was building Trump Tower yeah
and the enormous tax cut that he got to
build Trump Tower so when the city goes
and regulates something for safety of
the people who bought those cheaply
designed and you know they weren't used
the worst materials they had the lady
that constructed him she was appalled by
it but it's for the safety of these
people they that moved in there that pay
those taxes that he didn't have to pay
for him to skip this safety measure yeah
especially being the president the
United States after the Grenfell Tower
incident it's just infuriating to me
it's like if you get these tax credits
from the city of New York you should
have to follow their laws and there
should be no grandfather sure yeah
wellness and that's not again that's not
unique to Trump of course no and as
usual Trump responding and what is the
worst possible way right someone died
here and Trump went on Twitter and
rather than I don't know offering like a
condolence for the fact that someone
died Trump tweeted fire at Trump Towers
out very confined well-built building
well-built building which of course was
only as well-built as it is because of
the regulations that were in place
otherwise Trump would have cut either
more corners right were even more
corners were it not for the regulations
that governed how this building was
built aside from not having sprinklers
it would have been an even worse
building Pat well I like that he put
fire men and fire women oh yes job it's
very gender area galas here we got that
well absolutely also this is just a
weird detail but Trump reportedly
referred to the guy that died once as a
crazy Jew which again I mean none of
these each one of these details in
another presidency would have warranted
like a longer period of discussion
it's an aside that Trump won
allegedly referred to the guys a crazy
Jew yeah we don't even have anything to
add because it's just completely
expected that there would be some kind
of ad hominem like that let's take a
break give us a like on Facebook at
facebook.com slash David Pakman show
back after this today's program is made
possible in part by fruit or which is a
social forecasting game for your phone
where players come together and compete
with each other to predict future events
you go on the app find a future event
you feel confident enough about to make
a prediction and make a bet on the
outcome that you think will happen using
the apps in game fake currency if your
prediction is right you're rewarded with
more points you can compete with others
who are making their own prediction to
see who is the best forecaster there's
no real world money or cryptocurrency
involved the fun of future is
interacting with others and showing the
world your skills at predicting the
future will Democrats take the White
House house this year will Trump run for
re-election will trump ever build the
wall you can go ahead and make your
predictions show off your forecasting
skills and there are also monthly
competitions and prizes for top
forecasters and I'm on foote or you can
wager on my predictions you can also
browse the politics category for lots of
interesting questions to go to fruit or
calm to sign up and make forecast it's
free it's on Android and iOS as well as
on web browsers and it's spelled fut you
you are calm